Sabrina, you look stunning.
I mean seriously, I'm stunned.
♪ Ooh she's sitting with you
but her eyes are on the door ♪
♪ Strange magic ♪
I didn't have a costume, but is this okay?
You're
beautiful.
♪ Watching and waiting ♪
♪ Ooh she's sitting with
you but her eyes are on ♪
Welcome to Baxter High.
Not quite as magical as the academy.
Are you kidding?
Being here with you,
getting to see this other
side of you, it's...
It's more magical than
anything at the academy.
May I have this dance, m'lady?
You most certainly may.
♪ Here she comes ♪
(slow rock music)
Hey, what'd you wish for?
More of this.
♪ Nothing is new ♪
♪ I've seen her here before ♪
♪ Watching and waiting ♪
♪ Ooh she's sitting with you
but her eyes are on the door ♪
I love you, Sabrina.
I always have
and I always will.
(slow rock music)
Wanna see the rest of the school?
Are you asking me to sneak off with you
and go somewhere private?
Lead the way, Spellman.
They're coming to get you, Barbara.
Harvey Kinkle, the only person
you're gonna scare is
yourself! (screaming)
Gotcha.
(orchestral music swells)
Now what?
We lay side by side
soaking up the moon.
Hmmm
(twinkling piano music)
How long do we do this for?
All night long
till dawn.
Sounds amazing.
Harvey.
(serene orchestral music)
I love you, Sabrina.
I was gonna wait until
your birthday to say that
but since we maybe can't
celebrate together this year, I--
I'm glad you didn't.
I love it and you.
(serene orchestral music)
Why do you lie so far away from me?
Come closer.
I will not lie beneath you,
but only by your side.
Is that what you said
to your husband Adam?
Aren't you cold, woman?
Yes, I've been cold since the garden.
Come closer, then
and I'll keep you warm.
(orchestral music swells)
Harvey.
Sabrina.
♪ Treat me bad because I crave you ♪
♪ I can't fight back but I can take it ♪
♪ Treat me bad baby I'm prayin' ♪
♪ You hold my heart ♪
I missed you so much, Harvey.
I missed you too, Sabrina.
♪ Won't you hold my heart ♪
(slow orchestral music)
(twinkling orchestral music)
Before you keep looking.
♪ You're slipping ♪
♪ Under a spell ♪
♪ Live in your head and
smile at the devil ♪
I'm here for you, 'Brina.
Always, you know that.
I do.
I so do.
You're pretty special, Spellman.
I don't wanna mess things up with you.
(foreboding orchestra music)
There's no flying in my life
without you, Sabrina Spellman.
(orchestra music swells)
I'm here now
for whatever you need.
This is uncharted territory, Nick.
Do you think you can handle it?
What are warlock boyfriends for?
(twinkling orchestral music)
You're always there to catch me.
Will you get everyone out here
and be the one to catch me if I fall?
I will.
I love you, Harvey.
I'll always love you.
(cheering in background)
Nick, I'm about to step off a cliff
into the great unknown
and you're the one by my side,
holding my hand.
(twinkling orchestral music)
I love you too much to risk
anything bad happening to you.
(tense orchestral music)
I sat with you at lunch because of
the way you sang in choir class.
Do you remember that?
You were fearless
and I fell hard.
Can I...
Can I get one last kiss?
(foreboding operatic music)
I'm the best binder and
conjurer since Edward Spellman.
If anyone can keep him trapped, it's me.
Do it, Mr. Scratch.
Nick, Nick!
I love you, Spellman.
You taught me how to love.
Will you stay with me?
All night long.
(soft piano music)